you look good you take care yeah quit  boozing you quit yeah hi laid off  Thanksgiving weekend I just decided I  was gonna stop well that's that's was it  becoming a problem or yeah I will say  I'm a binge drinker I'm not an alcoholic  I thought it was an alcoholic but then I  went to one of the meetings I was like  all right these people are out of their  minds I mean I drink but these people  are insane yeah I just kept hearing the  stories I'd be like and then you quit  right and then they just would keep  going yeah my mom was laying there she  was reaching for a respirator I just saw  that cold beer in the counter this  little cigarettes yeah